60 minutes dives into the supply chain
issues on sunday's broadcast theoretical
reports from the ports of los angeles
and long beach to find out exactly
what's going on
now with inflation the highest in years
and the holidays fast approaching
there's a flurry of plans to break the
log jam
starting monday jean soroka who runs the
la ports says he'll find the shipping
lines for any cargo that sits on the
docks more than nine days and last month
president joe biden announced the ports
had agreed to work round the clock but
it hasn't had much effect
we typically work about 19 hours a day
here it's that three to eight am shift
that we've added and tried to get others
to work with us during those times as
well
so
you might be working 24 7 but the
warehouses are not that's right so they
have no place for these goods to go
after they get off the ship at three
o'clock in the morning and there you've
just diagnosed the problem
the cargo has nowhere to go we've got to
get a workforce in the warehouses and
the trucking industry that are
complementary to all this cargo that is
that's coming in right now
there is a lot of finger pointing yes
there is the truckers blame the
terminals the terminals blame the
shippers the retailers blame the
truckers and the shippers how do you get
that contentious group
to sit at the table stop pointing
fingers and actually clear out this
backlog that's been the toughest part we
haven't moved the needle yet but it's
not for a lack of trying we're going to
have to just double down
you can see the full story this sunday
on 60 minutes right here on cbs